brooke est revenu sur la rivalité qui
opposait dans les années 90 est inconnu
au nul et il a déclaré aujourd'hui je
n'y crois qu'il n'y a pas photo entre
les nuls et les inconnus tony glande il
sait bigard jacques martin c'est de la
parodie alors que les sketches des
inconnus
tout le monde s'en souvient ce n'est pas
de notre faute si on est plus populaire
que aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est
complètement ouf parce que voilà c'est
dénivelé en ce moment drôle nuls et les
inconnus va surtout très vite vous vous
prenez partie d'un amour qui voulaient
les inconnus ou jean-michel jeu les
inconnus parce que je sais pas peut-être
pas culture moche mais c'est plus
populaires j'ai vraiment marrer avec eux
voilà pour moi c'est qu'on laisse croire
des vrais ce que je fais et ouardi
l'autre un peu bobo le nul mais je
respecte mais moi je suis très ami avec
alain chabat un peu moins même pourquoi
les bills nuls les nuls c'est canal+
canal+ c'est la classe absolue
c'est dire si moi je dis je raconte
tenue lundi le butin mais c'est pas
possible d'être aussi grossier 6 et les
nuls dit levon c'est du génie pur c'est
un diamant
ja c'est d'abord et c'est le truc canard
et donc c'est pour ça que moi je peux
faire les inconnus parce qu'ils sont
extrêmement impopulaire d'un petit repos
une des choses que tout le monde
reconnaît que des références absolues
moi je voulais que je vous dise la
vérité et je le dis même si je suis
extrêmement ami avec dominique farrugia
dont il farrugia me fait extrêmement
riche mais c'est vrai que les uns sur
les inconnues
moi ça a été serré que moi je compte y
était plus dans la cour oui on parlait
des inconnus c'est très populaire assez
simples inconnus font un film qui fait
13 millions tu vois les trois frères les
nul n'aurait pas plu après c'est vrai
que à cause d'un achat il est très
difficile de critiquer les nuls dès
qu'on critique est nu à l'ehpad moi je
suis fan des deux je suis fan des nuls
et des impôts lorsque mon père en 85 il
a eu tout de suite canal+ mais eux ils
avaient moins de les imiter parce qu'ils
étaient sur canal même à claire et il
faisait des émissions à 22h après ça
vient
l'inconnu on parle à la cour d'école
parce que c'était sur france 2 il y
avait beaucoup plus de visibilité aux si
c'est vrai alors on va voir juste ce
sondage c'est très tard les nus à bas
les inconnus à 4% et enfin le couple le
plus en vue du moment c'est justin
bieber est allé baldwin qui après
l'annoncé de leur mariage sont ce mois
ci en une du très chic magazine vogue
on y retrouve des photos du couple mais
aussi une interview dans laquelle le
chanteur se confie sur ses problèmes de
drogue et son addiction au sexe %
soigner il explique s'être privé de
relations sexuelles pendant un an pour
régler son rapport au sexe et se
rapprocher de dieu
[Applaudissements]
c.de à crossac chirac attentes de 20 60
balais tu vas voir ça va tout seul mois
avant ma play beat dassier est longue de
velours maintenant c'est plutôt
l'inversé la masse des parents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
françois berléand et ses propos sur les
gilets jaunes cité sur notre ami eric vu
ça un sur rtl choquée pas choqué des
propos sans langue de bois pour créer la
polémique
là on voit qu'il ya 90 % des français
qui soutiennent et gilet jaune
et puis deux semaines après la pub 88 70
maple début ils me font chier les gilets
jaunes si léger des jaunes n'ont pas
conscience de qui a des gens qui
travaillent que ça coûte de l'argent que
les manifestations qui ont dégénéré à
paris machin sas les assurances qui ont
payé donc les assurances c'est quoi qui
va payer on essaie eux aussi qu'ils
m'ont payé
donc voilà tout le monde paye mais quand
vous dites ça vous avez conscience quand
même qui empêche le sevn qui vont se
tenir ce genre de discours déjà
publiquement dans bien demain on va bien
médiatiquement gagna mairie conséquence
tout ça mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ] moi
je m'en fiche pour la bonne raison que
je ne suis pas dans les réseaux sociaux
alors valérie bénaïm pas choqué non le
fond de ce qu'ils disent suis pas là
pour prendre parti pour dire s'il a tort
ou à raison en revanche on est dans une
démocratie
donc on a le droit ou non mais on a le
droit de dire ce que l'on pense et parle
et on a le droit de dire ce qu'ils
pensent oui mais alors jean marie moi je
suis choqué par ce qu'il dit parce que
il démarre sa phase en disant ils se
rendent pas compte que les gens qui
travaillent mais les gilets jaunes ils
travaillent
c'est pas des clochards c'est pas des
demandeurs d'emploi c'est pas des mecs
qui veulent du fric c'est des mecs qui
bossent [ __ ] de leur mère toute leur
vie eh bien le 20 du mois ils sont comme
ça au ils ont rien compris c'est des
mecs en colère moi je souhaite que les
jets les jeunes deviennent une
révolution mondiale en est champion du
monde de la révolution et e
je souhaite que l'on aille à la chasse
aux gros et pas à la chasse aux petits
comme un con il vient saignée des gens
qui ont déjà plus de sang dans les
veines
il aurait dû dire j'ai été con j'aurais
dû aller vous dire on va faire la chasse
aux gros on peut pas taxer la marine
marchande me va taxer l'aviation parce
que c'est une loi internationale alors
changeons cette loi internationale
devenons les vrais révolue
pioneer de toute la planète si jamais on
veut vraiment aller à la chasse aux gros
on y va une quarantaine de tankers
bouffe autant de fioul que tout les
bagnoles de la planète
alors allons chercher des milliards où
ils sont mais elles n'ont pas suivi
[Applaudissements]